what the f is going on i like to part
jesus honey this is unwaxed
get in loser we're going shopping with
sophia and sistine stallone do we just
become best friends yep
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax
podcast with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine stallone watch out
she's going to american idol with those
pipes
i think our brains are a little bit
scrambled right now because we just
finished
an interview with a psychic that we had
previously on the show before chris
medina
and oh my gosh you guys will hear it
later in this episode
woof woof is right i don't know what to
think
he is just so accurate and he just
i guess with the second reading he he
got us on a deeper level but you know
if anything it just kind of motivates us
i feel like gets us back on track
because
regardless if you think things like this
are real or not when you have someone
say
you're not showing your full potential
you're not doing the things you should
be doing
it's different it's different and you're
like you know what you're so [ __ ]
right
get me off tick tock yes for the last 12
hours i am
using it until bed like i'm wasting my
time
this episode is is so much fun you guys
are gonna love it
i highly recommend listening to the
first one we had with chris medina i
think it was
episode 14 yeah that we had him on go
back listen to that one
come back listen to this one it'll make
a lot more sense of what we're talking
about
but before we'll get into the interview
i think we'll do a little bit of a
weekly update
yeah we have some big news big news
we finally found a place to live
yay right now you guys are probably
thinking why did it take you
six months i thought you were moving to
miami i thought you were getting an
apartment
i thought you're getting a house i
thought you were still living at home
thought you were looking for a roommate
all of those things
you're right it did take a bit but
good things come in time and i think
genuinely this has been
if anyone's actually been looking for a
place before
you even if you're still living with
parents apartment hunting or anything
hunting
is so hard especially living
in california because everything is
getting booked up everyone is coming out
everything's like
everything is so expensive and yes you
guys we are uh paying for it so
we were trying to find something
reasonable and we did it i'm not gonna
tell you also
you little stalkers if it's a house an
apartment a townhouse
a shack or a car a tent i'm not gonna
tell you where it is either
it's a school bus it is a school bus but
i think it's pretty funny because we
started this podcast
um with the intention of having people
sort of watch us become adults and try
adulting things and experience
relationships and moving out and and
this is one of those
one of those moments you guys look at us
we're 40 what two episodes in and we are
[ __ ] up in the adult world i feel
like it's taken
i've realized a couple things with um
apartment house whatever hunting
you have to go there you don't just look
at it online i mean like
no but i feel like there's sometimes we
were like oh we like it but we won't
check it out yet or kind of like leave
it
the place we like we weren't about to go
check out really go in
look at the environment see sistine i
went into one
do you want to talk about what you did
in one of the houses that we looked at
oh my gosh
sophia found this little house it was so
cute perfect
three bedroom but i noticed something
really strange
in every closet there was stairs to an
attic
and i go okay interesting yeah
all right and then there was one door
that had two
locks on it yeah and i go from the
outside from the outside i was like what
is what is behind this door without
hesitation
pretty surprised you would do this
sophia unlocks both of the locks
and it is the eeriest basement
y'all have ever seen i'm just gonna
describe what it looks like think about
this
you open the door it's a white door it
goes
wooden steps go down steep steps yeah
into darkness it's pitch black
and it's pitch black literally it looks
like there is no bottom
right we find a light switch sophia goes
down there
i was like very bright i i wanted to be
a part of
maybe potentially a new movie that came
out that was based on me
because you could fully shoot a horror
movie genuinely you could have sophia
thought it'd be funny i'm at the top of
the stairs
to scream out of nowhere and my mom
nearly fell on her ass when she did this
well i turned the corner and i go
okay i have an opportunity here there i
could pretend there's a dead body
a serial killer that was locked but you
didn't get the last laugh did you
no you can't punk me sofia so steve gets
pissed
i thought as punishment you deserved
this at the least
i switch off the lights and lock the
door i
have never ever been
so scared in my entire life like i i
didn't think i was scared of the dark
i was claustrophobic it was pitch black
but
you fully deserve it oh i was scared but
the thing is i don't understand
why someone will create a door that
literally looks like a part of
every single friggin horror film that
you've ever seen
and lock it from the outside like we
could keep a person in there
i think maybe we should keep someone
down there i think so
maybe you know scratching and weird
noises all the time
but anyway find a boyfriend trap him
oh my kind of love that energy honestly
thank you
um so we so another reason why sophie
and i are a little bit
i think you you're a little mad at me
for this next thing
sophia and i we're deciding on our new
place
who's gonna get the bigger bedroom now
let me let me
set the scene the bigger bedroom has
three times the size of the closet way
bigger sink
way bigger bathroom a fireplace so if
you want to get all austin powers in
there you can
i mean it's a vibe in the bigger bedroom
and
we were trying to think of ways that we
could decide on who would get it we
can't do anything competitive we said
we're switching after six months
we couldn't do anything competitive
because we'd say she cheated she started
first blah blah blah so my mom goes
you did cheat this is hilarious my mom
goes
i'm going to write down a number and
y'all are going to say a number between
one and a hundred right now
right now hold on let me explain it
she's so bitter
i said because it's [ __ ] let me
explain
i was the one that started it shut up
sistine my mom writes down a number
between 1 and 100.
sophia immediately says 35
and i thought okay either i am stupid
pies let me explain this is why i have
to
interject so my mom writes down a number
and for some reason in my
gut first number that came in my head
was 35
i just i got chills i was like this is
it
i won i like knew i was in my home like
i
won the room right and i'm like i'm
gonna get it for my birthday it's gonna
be like summer
and this is what i thought either i play
smart
or i or i play creative either i'm going
to go with my mom's favorite number or
should i guess 36 odds are in my favor
i say 36. and then in my head i go
[ __ ] i was an idiot because i said the
number out loud we should have written
it down
now i don't know if i'm on some psychic
level [ __ ] right now
my mom nearly flies backwards she shows
the number it's 36.
oh my this is
literal [ __ ] because if we had
written down the numbers i would have
won
but my confident ass who i knew
i knew i was going to get it right i was
like 35
and i didn't even think this [ __ ]
could choose
with sophia there's a lesson there's a
lesson in all of this what
work smarter not harder sweetie thank
you
thank you hi so um yeah
i was so bitter i mean i'm still a
little bitter but
thankfully after six months we get to
switch but
definitely not not my happiest i was
just having
losses that entire day i was just not a
happy person you were very honest
so that was just the start of the
morning and my mom's like that's fair
and i was just
like no it's not whatever but it's it's
gonna be fun
we're really excited moving together
we're trying to think of funny quirks to
have
included into our place i found all
these naked body candles that i thought
might be cool
just a bunch of naked candles i i always
say that we should design it
very simple contemporary some maybe some
modern but then
add really fun accentuating pieces that
keep it very alive and
uh quirky and i want someone to walk
into our place and go
this is their place like this is the
stallone girls is
like every time i'm walking around if
you guys have any suggestions to really
make it
i guess unique in a very strange odd way
you did have one
yesterday you're showing me the photo
oh i think we should do that's a good
idea a roommate family photo
like you know the like ugly sweaters on
the mantel with like the big glasses and
it kind of looks like a faded
that'll be cute i think that'd be cute
but also that place has a little
bar in there so it's five o'clock
somewhere
maybe we should get some illuminating
light like we have here with unwax
should we should we bring in our guest
so you guys we have such an exciting and
really fun episode we've been looking
forward to this for so long because
everything that this man has said has
come true
and sistine and i are here to say
it is legit it is real he has guessed
our romances he's guessed our career and
he's guessed our personalities not
guests
predicted listen up on waxers we have
the fabulous
chris medina joining us not only did he
come in with flowers today and just melt
my freaking heart also guys take notes
what the hell
flowers so easy to do yeah don't wear a
hoodie on a date bring flowers
he he
is here with us today we are so lucky to
have him on for the second time
so stay tuned i just feel this energy
coming across the table right now don't
you feel it's
yes i've been on the way here i was
saying to him i'm like i feel this
nervous jitter but excited because we've
been looking forward to seeing you
one day once again my fingertips are
numb
so let me just introduce them let me
just introduce them back
for the second time on the unwaxed
podcast we have the gifted
chris medina joining us ladies and
gentlemen
let me just give a little background
about who you are
he has dedicated his life to giving
psychic and medium readings with the
goal to provide
people with no [ __ ] spiritual advice
he is changing lives
all over the world while breaking down
the stigma of psychics while he's at it
chris thank you so much for coming back
i love you guys you guys are amazing
thank you so much for having me back
oh my god so the first time we had you
on the show
i would say how many months almost a
year ago yeah today kind of it was no no
it was like in november i would say
right
it was right or november one of the most
surreal
i've i've really never gotten a proper
reading before yeah i mean either and a
lot of the things that you had
predicted for us was six
seven months down the line so we
couldn't really say whether it was true
or not
well you know what it was was that
things were happening to sistine and i
that
we we weren't really thinking about the
things you said but things would be
happening you go wait a minute
that's kind of interesting and so one
day i think it was last month we
sat and re-watched the episode and we
lost
our [ __ ] i can't wait to hear it i can't
oh my god i mean do you want to just
like
go into it how about we'll start with
we'll explain like things that you've
said
before and maybe you can also give us
like an update on what you said
absolutely that's what i'm here for
oh my gosh okay so one of the things you
did say
was that sistine and i would find you
said i would find my person in
february and that he'd be into music and
i don't think you necessarily said it
was going to be a long term thing but
you said it was going to be like a mini
relationship
fully happened this kid was like into
djing
um it was like it happened literally
i met him the 31st of january and we
started
kind of like talking and going out
february first oh my gosh
i know so a short term short list sure
yeah yeah i mean like keys across the
country but one of the main
things you absolutely nailed was when we
were recording
our podcast the first time with you on
it the only thing that we really had
going for us was the podcast
that was sort of just our our priority
that was our only goal and that was our
job full time now you had told us
february
and march of 2021 you're going to meet
you called it the guest stars of our
lives business-wise
so you still haven't met the person
that's really going to pivot your career
in a big way yeah and sophia and i are
thinking well what the heck
we have no idea what else we want to do
how could this happen yeah you kept
saying that this isn't it there's
something bigger that's going to happen
oh for sure
and let me tell you oh god okay middle
of february
we get a call and we can't give all the
details we're not allowed to details
but we can't give the details on the
show right now but we get a call
from a huge company asking to meet with
us
and sort of the best way i can describe
it is
make our podcast on an even larger
platform
a platform that we never even imagined
in a million never considered
and it is such a career-changing
opportunity life-changing opportunity
so the fact that you nailed that hold on
hold on hold on another thing you nailed
was at the end of our episode we showed
you photos of our
ex-boyfriends and we said what do you
see
long-term sophie and i were dabbling
with maybe becoming friends
maybe getting back together we needed
you for some guidance
and you told both of us just friends
let me tell you we got friend-zoned
hearts oh my god
wow and we thought this guy you know
he's the real deal so
that's sort of our update but let me
just before you guys finish let me just
tell you guys
again i'm going to say this out loud you
guys are not done growing and anybody
could say
oh it doesn't take a psychic to realize
that but look at the world's opening
back up yeah things are coming back into
fruition here
so get ready get ready actually
we can just start getting into it let's
do it give me my little spill here we go
so um before we get into it um i just
want to let you know that i do not
discuss
death and i do not discuss anything
that's going to scare the [ __ ] out of
you
so with that being said is there
anything that you want me to stay away
from
no no perfect the second thing is for
the first couple minutes of the reading
i'm going to go in and give you what my
guides are giving me to give you guys
directly and then i'll open the reading
up to any questions that you have in
regards to what i said
or if you want to know about something
that we didn't get a chance to touch on
we could do it at that time does that
work yes
perfect and then the final final thing
is your time is very important and
expensive to me i want you to feel free
to jump in at any time to call
[ __ ] do not hold back do not worry
about trying to be polite not wanting to
hurt my feelings none of that
if it doesn't resonate or if it sounds
off let me know when i do hit stuff
simply confirm yes but do not give me
any additional details see that was my
problem last time i feel like i'm on a
roller coaster
she's hot so you guys ready you wanna do
this let's do it okay
so again i'm gonna go ahead and make
these predictions here um i'm gonna say
it out loud i do not feel like you guys
are done growing and evolving um it's
great that you guys are gonna do
something together
but also look for separate opportunities
aside from each other
because you guys both have different um
and this is something that again i'm
just going to shout out your fans real
fast yeah and say i love them
oh they are so cool yeah they are great
they are so
um uh down to earth and so welcoming and
so warm and just receptive to what i had
what i have to say
and so i'm going to say that for on
their behalf hello to you guys that's
what they want to say all the time
but uh your fans your fans um
know the differences between you guys
and i see the differences between you
guys as well too so
look for those joint ventures but also
don't be afraid to branch out and go on
your own because you guys
both bring a lot of different things to
the table as individuals
right so i have a feeling what's going
to end up happening here and this is
probably going to be towards
look for a time frame around the end of
october getting ready to go into
november of this month i don't know what
you guys have planned for that time
but there's going to be here we go with
the guest stars of our lives and then
also the guest opportunities that come
in
is this in terms of separately like are
like different
opportunities coming to us separately or
together in october i think it's going
to be together
but i also think i also think what's
going to end up happening is i'm not
going to say that they're going to try
to split you guys up
but they might offer different
opportunities for the both of you yeah
so don't be afraid to take on those
because because all you guys can always
come back full circle
does that make sense yes that does make
sense and also too how are the
relationships going with you guys don't
lead me into it though but how is that
how's everything going
and um between us or in with like
romantic romantic-wise
um so far we're just single pringles
i mean we you know i i won't give too
much but basically cecina are at a point
where we're
now settling down and calming and
opening up to more
something that's substantial rather than
i'll i'll tell you what you said last
time was that we would both
be in um some form of a relationship
at in the same month in the same period
of time and that was 100 correct
and the only issue is just the long
distance so
at the moment we are single okay well i
don't see that happening i don't see it
staying for like that for very long
really
so but here's the thing though remember
i told you i'm not to pick on you
but you're a little bit more slow to
warm than she is you've got she's got
more details that she wants
her but she's got more boxes on her form
that they need to check off i'm not
saying that you're easy and that you're
like more
she is so picky sophia yes but that's a
good thing though
be picky yeah because you have to
realize and i'm not just saying this
because i'm sitting in front of your
face
but you guys have to realize what you
guys bring to the table so do not
settle okay and for somebody like you
like i told you what's going up
happening here i know there was an
episode where you guys were talking
about having kids
and how you're going to be
you're like no no i'm not nothing
negative when it comes to that but
i think that
i think it's going to be a little bit
more of a um
i think she's going to be a little bit
more loose with her kids what does that
mean
like more kind of like um not as
distracting multiple baby daddies
no raising
yeah not that you don't have the
character or you're not funny like that
but she's a little bit more laid back
she's gonna make fun of that kid she's
going to see what that kid's doing so
i'll be the cool aunt
and with you you're going to be more
detailed you're going to be more kind of
like
i'm going to put i'm going to put them
in the best schools i'm going to do this
i'm going to do that i want to raise
them eating this kind of food and blah
blah so again i don't see anything
negative when it comes
out also with the dating stuff too your
guides are still screaming at me to tell
you about
your vulnerability and not to be afraid
to open up is especially with the right
person
yeah and i am so closed off to everyone
i feel like
i'm the most open but closed off person
you'll ever meet and i'm going to tell
you that's your intuition
i feel like you're picking up i'm going
to say this over and over again i think
you're picking you're into you're
picking up on the intention of the other
person
whether they're nervous or whatever
whatever isn't said can make you a
little bit nervous or question what's
going on there and then you're thinking
is this my fault or or are they looking
at me like like uh there's something
wrong with me
right no see that's the thing is i feel
like i never give anybody the
opportunity because the moment i have to
be
vulnerable with them i think i overthink
and i think okay if they're not perfect
for this moment for this scene for this
family
i just shut it off even if it works or
just seeing how it naturally flows
or let it play i never just let it play
out and so that's why i'm getting
nervous is because i was saying that my
mom the other day i was like
i really want to be open and meet
someone and like actually
make a connection with some that's
longer than just a couple months but
i have this really hard time doing it
and that's all i want and i don't know
if i'm going to end up choosing
the right person because i'm just going
to go for people that i think i need
maybe you're overthinking it
see again i'm probably you're
overthinking it the reason why i'm
saying that is because
you you know what you want when it comes
to a relationship yeah and they have to
come at you in a different type of way
sure they're going to come across a
little bit shy yeah but there's
something there that's going to let you
know
oh my god like you said i felt all
tingly before i came in here i felt a
little bit nervous whatever
i have a feeling that person is going to
do the same thing to you oh really
so don't worry about that stuff and
don't be afraid to be vulnerable i'm not
telling you to sit there and tell them
everything all at one time but let go a
little bit okay little by little and see
and
and venture out because that's important
for your progression and your growth
right as far as like what's going on on
the inside with you
okay with you i'm not so worried about
it
really i'm not i'm not worried about it
all i think i think with you that
um jealous i would be no i would be a
little bit more
concerned with quality for you
wow because
let's be honest here neither one of you
guys are gonna have a difficult time
finding somebody right it's the quality
but you what ends up happening with you
is that uh she's gonna be a little bit
more on guard because of who she is so
she's not gonna i'm not saying that
you're dumb or that you're falling for
their lines
but the minute that they say something
sweet or they or they because they can
count on that because you i just looking
at your emotions
they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna tug at that you're gonna like oh
my god they're the nicest person ever
and then she's gonna say
well let's just wait a minute you just
you just met them sistine
blah blah yes but at the same time again
i
i love that about you i think what i'm
gonna say this again i think that the
person that you end up getting involved
with
is gonna capitalize off of your
sensitivity and i also feel like what
they're going to do is be more of that
protector that security
in the relationship daddy yeah daddy
wait so that actually this is why we're
a good balance is because i think that
when it comes to anything friendships or
relationships you need
that person to do the opposite for you
like she's like my boyfriend
she is my boyfriend right now like she
brings out my emotional side and then i
bring out
her high high standard side where i'm
like no you deserve someone that does
this more than just giving you half half
asset she tells me
relax open up and i think that that's
follow him and that's like the one good
thing that i have is like if i was on my
own i would be
i'd be a one with eight cats by myself
and probably choosing a sperm donor
because i'm so picky
so in terms because there's a big thing
that's coming up for both of us and
we do want to get into these
relationships i think our concern is
really making sure that
whoever we're going to end up being with
can kind of really go along with what
opportunity we have as our plan is and
or do you think
that timeline wise with having maybe
this is not even our husband but maybe
like a
serious relationship do you think it's
coming before
this opportunity or do you think it's
coming after like when do you see us
i think it's gonna coincide with each
other okay i think but i think that i
think what's going to what's going to
take
place first is your guys's careers yeah
and getting that nailed down because
it's one less thing for you to worry
about and also to
get one last time guess what that's
going to do it's going to bring
the guest stars of your lives into your
lives right
so those opportunities you guys have you
guys don't know who's going to be on set
or you don't know where where you're
going to be at who you're going to talk
to
what that's going to bring so don't
overthink it just focus on you right now
and especially you getting out of your
head and allowing yourself to be a
little bit more vulnerable
you i'm not going to say toughen up i
don't want to see you toughen up do it i
just want to
toughen up i want to i want i want to
see
i want to see you um
not to be selective is the wrong word to
that shitty i would tell you i know
exactly what you're saying
it's almost like don't let everyone in
just because they're nice to you
i think that i i think that you guys are
going to again i can't manipulate this
because again it hasn't happened i don't
want to change your minds but i feel
like you guys are going to do this in a
very practical and logical type of way
when it comes to that transition of do
we just have them move in and take it
from there
yeah like we just you know we just live
together for right now and then when we
decide that it's you know too
too close for comfort here then we just
leave okay but i feel like again i'm
going to steal from what you said and
again i don't want to make it seem like
i'm excluding you my love
but i feel like with you when it comes
to this relationship i'm going to steal
from what you said i think i said this
the last time too
maybe not a marriage right away but uh
uh a power couple type of mentality
where we look
not bad though no because this is the
thing this is what i'm worried about i
i i i've been good no i i am over
thinking but i am going to quit i'm this
is my personality
i have this fear though because i do
want that and i want someone that is
just as ambitious and has things going
on
but i also don't want someone that is
like completely separate from me where
we really don't have a genuine
relationship and there's like no love in
the household that
she's overthinking
you're over there you don't know you
don't know what he's gonna say to you
during that time frame you don't you
don't know what his personality is going
to be like you don't know how he's going
to be able to handle you
you don't know what words of wisdom he's
going to say like to get inside your
head
to talk you out of that i mean isn't
that all you want at the end of the day
hold on overthinker isn't that what you
want at the end of the day
it doesn't matter what your your status
is
married long-term just someone being
with someone that understands you and
your brain and knows how to pick you up
and calm you down i mean
well i
if everything crumbles down i actually
want to know that the person
that this power dynamic isn't going to
be destroyed alongside our relationship
you know you're going to be tested you
are going to be tested i cannot steal
i cannot manipulate you and i can't i
cannot tell you exactly what's going to
happen
but think about what you're saying here
you you this is the guy that you are
going to pick this is the guy that you
are going to be dating
so there has to be something about him
that is like
some type of romantic aspect to him
right and let's just say you obviously
know that i'm
very gay but if i was dating you there
is no way in hell
there is no way in hell that i would
allow you and not not
pinning you down but to to talk me out
of
talking to you or you flip the table
around and be like oh i'm going to get
up or i'm going to go
this year no you're going to sit down
and we're going to talk about this
because you need to learn how to relax
right
that's it okay and with her it just
again that's what i told you from the
last time
about the guy that comes in from you how
your family is going to love him yes
yeah still the same thing really i don't
i don't feel
i'm telling you so what you had said
last time was that my family
is going to highly approve of him he's
going to propose in front of the family
yeah that's like and he's going to work
hard to make them happy as well
and i think that you're welcome jennifer
this is nothing this is nothing like
your your guy's not going to be romantic
but i almost wonder if he's going to say
i would have loved to done that but i
don't i don't want to bring that type of
attention to you
i like it and make you feel yeah see
your you guys see
it's hot in here and i'm getting
goosebumps
if somebody comes in don't hesitate to
reach out and be like chris what do you
think of this guy
is this see do that i gotta do that you
have to
i was just saying i'll do it right now i
just said you should bring up someone
because i got it
i don't bring up a photo right now i
don't have anybody
anyone right there come on i will do it
let me tell you
like i said can i have like a boyfriend
for at least like six months someone i
actually can
something that you could practice on
just like yeah yeah i don't but this
thing i'm not looking for marriage
seem to have said that i'm not looking
for a husband right now i'm really
really set on this
we're gonna get into the career a bit
more okay chris let's look at this photo
tell me what you see
i'm curious to see who you're showing i
think that he can be
a little bit intimidating for her
sometimes because she doesn't know where
he's coming from
does that make sense as far as like the
way that he carries himself
can be can be kind of like um i think
that you're
does he talk the game does he talk does
he talk a good game oh yeah well now he
does yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah adorable she gets
all the really cute ones
yeah well yeah and clearly we don't have
it figured out
we are still young you know is there
something that's going to happen in the
future for us that's sort of maybe going
to
switch that mentality that we have i
don't think you guys have come into
yourselves again
don't for for somebody to say that first
of all it's shitty but i'm gonna explain
that i'm gonna sweeten this up here yeah
i don't think that you guys have come
into yourself and
realized your potential and i'm not just
gonna throw the stallone name in there
but realize what you guys can do
as individuals just yet so mark my words
when
when when the career starts to take off
and you guys are starting to get these
deals you guys are starting to get more
exposure and do all this other stuff
here
watch how that's going to open you guys
up and then it's going to make you
realize you're worth and then you guys
gonna have to be dealing with
the thing who can we trust and who can
we do right so that's our main problem
so we have this thing
that's coming up and um it's with this
big network and
we are just concerned that this might
not even happen
that we'll have to like wait a couple
more months or maybe another year
to kind of get this like opportunity let
me manipulate you guys let me manipulate
you one time
i'm gonna be honest with this your
guides because you're i've mentioned
your guys's family
bloodline this has nothing to do with
your dad of who he is now and realizing
who your grandmother is and all that
stuff
right you have to realize something you
guys are not going to be thrown into
stuff
or or led down a path that's going to be
shitty for you guys you guys are very
and i hate saying this because it sounds
too metaphysical but you guys are very
protected
you guys do have your guides on the
other side so if there are delays
realize that it's probably within our
best interest here because one you don't
want to be
painted in a bad light yeah and you also
want to make sure that
this is a long lasting type of thing do
you think that's exact
and do you think that that would happen
if this thing started
sooner than later i'm not worried about
that because i feel like with you your
instincts are going to kick in
you especially i'm sorry for pointing
but no please oh i don't care i feel i
feel like your instincts are gonna kick
in and don't do not be if i don't know
what your dad or your mom tells you but
do not be afraid to flex as you because
you have a way of thinking about [ __ ]
that maybe you're not gonna voice it
because you're like oh i didn't want to
say that because i don't want to come
across
rude or i don't want to overstep my
boundaries but if this has to do with
your career
do it well that's so funny as i was just
saying to my mom the other day i wanted
to speak on something and i just felt
uncomfortable i don't want to like push
my
opinion or my viewpoint or thoughts on
something that i don't want people to
react negatively but
i mean i feel like that's our problems
that we're probably not even as
pronounced on
our social media pages and the things
that we can be doing
like more so that would give us more
opportunities all the reading from last
time is coming back here so what
remember when i told you because there
this is not to leave you out of it
but this this is a reading for you right
now remember when i told you that i see
you more on the technical side of things
i see on the business side of things
yeah that's why i'm telling you love
don't be afraid to fly
resentment is a horrible color on you
yeah so don't that would be that way
don't be in that color i will be bitter
exactly you know me oh you know what i
know and stop comparing yourself to your
sisters
yeah because you stand on your own well
thank you for saying that because well i
look at her and i go she is like
so no i do i mean look i admire
everything that she's done she deserves
like i do not genuinely like she works
her ass off she deserves it
i mean she's gone through even more
rejection than i've ever gone in my
entire life and she's
for somebody that's sensitive you're
very vulnerable on the inside
you've got an amazing you're giving me
goosebumps you've got an amazing amount
of strength to where again i don't
you don't show it to the outside world
unless
you want to you've got a really good
poker face thank you
she doesn't continue to do that that's
why i said i'm not your guys's paths are
completely separate from one another you
really came back in this lifetime to
come into your power
and you're gonna again i'm not excluding
excluding you from love
but you came here to learn about
relationships to be to be in that
relationship to get married have kids
have a big family and all that
stuff that you didn't get a chance to do
do you see that all for me
yeah for sure and i thought that's why i
say that when you're up when you become
a mother
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
the way that your guys has raised your
kids where
her kid's probably going to be all put
together and neat and you're going to be
like it doesn't matter what you know
blah blah blah they're just
kids let them do this let them meet the
rollie pollies
am i going to be just an [ __ ] mom no
no no no no
are my kids gonna be the ones sneaking
out of the window and then i'm gonna be
like
because i'm so strict on yes he's
looking away oh no
your kids are gonna be i think your mom
is gonna jump in and be like you need to
relax a little bit she will
she will she will because i'm going to
be that person like i don't know how to
raise a kid or this is my first time and
so i'm going to try to be perfect with
everything then you just send it to
uncle chris's house and chris will take
care of exactly
uncle chris will take care of him this
will take care of him i love it i love
it
but you guys don't worry about it go get
go get what you came for okay pay
attention to what's going on especially
in the industry don't be afraid to ask
questions make bigger moves here because
the end of the day i feel like you i
feel like again
the two of you guys and then you guys
have another sister too right yes
younger sister
yeah she's yeah she's 18. you guys can
be a [ __ ] powerhouse
i'm telling you right now because again
okay get your faces out there
and everybody again i think you guys
have to be two of the most humblest
women that i know that are in the
industry
that don't real that don't realize where
you guys are at sometimes i think you
guys play it too safe
i sometimes i feel like we kind of be a
little dangerous
i know i feel like we need to be a
little louder why is it less like a
little more dangerous
oh my gosh oh hey i have one question do
you
see us with like a lot of kids each or
like a
one or do you think two or three or is
this i'm curious because
i know what gender i want or what kind
of order i want in gender but like
she already has the names picked out i
do have the names picked up i wouldn't
be surprised if
it was anywhere from like uh one to
three for you
okay for both of you yeah that's right
uh-huh yeah
do you know do you know if what gender
it would be first one
you're asking some heinous questions
what is the bloodline for the boys in
the family
so well so my mom's whole side
they only make one of a type my mom is
one of seven but all the girls
have had either all boys of all or all
girls and uh
my dad's side has either i think he's
had a all boys
that yeah yeah all boys all boys so it's
always been it hasn't i don't think
there's ever
a mix uh i don't want to steal your
sunshine or i don't i don't want to
again go too far down the rabbit hole
with this but there's going to be and
remember this because you guys are gonna
be like oh my god i can't believe this
uh there's gonna be one of the kids and
i can't see whose it is i i can't i'm
not
that's not a cop-out but there's gonna
be one that i feel like your dad or your
mom is gonna be like
this isn't this one's a character this
is like re uh the words i want to use is
replenishes or refreshens
that bloodline in some type of way where
the personality is more unique or more
kind of like uh
interesting i want to say jokester or or
made for television type of kid
and there's something that there's
something about that my dog buster i
call him my son
so i'm manifesting that and one of them
is going to have really super dark hair
like super dark dark hair yeah yeah
maybe it could be
either one of us but okay but i see the
family getting a kick out of this little
kid i don't know if there's a kid now
that you guys have in the family that
has that type of personality but this is
a kid to where you guys are like where
did he come from
oh my god we need that because it's like
when there's all girls there's so much
female energy really around us a lot and
our cousin round that lives with us he's
like the only guy in the household
and we've i've always said like we need
something to just kind of spark it up
whether that's like between our families
or whatever we end up having and
if that's the case perfect and i
wouldn't again i'm going to go too far
down the rabbit hole so which is so if
this doesn't come into fruition my bad
but i i think that it is
i think this is going to be something
that the public is going to see as well
too
so this could be like a show that you
guys are that you guys you guys have a
show going on while one of you guys is
pregnant and has the baby afterward
or whatever but i see this i see this
being like i'm not saying you guys i
don't want to say you guys are going to
be the next kardashians
but that's what i feel like is going to
yeah
so i definitely want to talk about this
next topic because
when we had you on the first time you
had mentioned how
this i don't know what you'd call it
this energy or these spirits or ghosts
had been keeping you up
and specifically there was a man that
was sort of
bothering you every single night and
wouldn't let you sleep and it was
speaking to you
has anything like that happened recently
oh every day
any story so what are what are some
recent encounters but also
on this another part two questions has
this been happening more so since
covid and quarantine because you've been
in isolation yeah
okay there's a lot there's a lot of um
you know a lot of i call them passerbys
or visitors uh the other night and even
uh you know jay who comes with yeah
he he's witnessed it too where he's like
oh my god i feel like a cat crawled up
the bed
and sat between my legs they'll push
down on the bed all that
it's all not everybody how do you sleep
at night
i would be going insane like melatonin
yeah
but uh it's more it's more psychic hits
it's more kind of like getting glimpses
into the future about what's to come
here again
advancements in technology when it comes
to the world uh again
don't worry um and i know the boat that
you guys are in about not wanting to uh
make yourselves look stupid or just jump
on anything or whatever and that's what
i'm doing too
is i'm not again i'm taking it slow i'm
figuring out how things are working
i don't want to uh come across in a way
to where we're just talking about medium
stuff the whole time
i want to bring what i do with you guys
into the forefront and start you know
yeah yeah really yeah but with the with
the ghost stuff
every day you can sometimes see physical
signs of
a ghost or spirit leaving their mark
that's so fascinating what are signs of
someone's house
being maybe more have like a possession
with it
no ouija boards no ouija boards no
boards
because that if again i don't know how
people feel about this portal that's the
portal
shut up i don't mess with it i've had i
you have to understand something i
i've been this my way it's been been
this way my whole life my sister
growing up had a friend that was heavily
into ouija board she was like eight or
nine years old i was about 10 or 11 at
that time
and those things are freaky it would it
would br it brought stuff into the house
to where um
we had a clock that used to plug in one
of those wall clocks that plugged into
the
that plugged in yeah stopped would go on
what would turn on by itself without it
being plugged in
the phone back then old school phone
would ring there was a little bell that
would ding every time give us a sign if
you're here
ding ding ding ding yeah oh geez and
also be
careful of who you have coming over
especially if you guys feel because
again
remember i don't know if i told you guys
a story but people especially this is
something that you should pay attention
to
uh the intention of other people
sometimes they can come in with a
negative energy on them like their
attachments
and leave it there you would be
vulnerable to it it would probably get a
hold of you psychologically
and it would cause her to be more
irritated or feel like there's something
wrong
that would happen i'm so it's
way more fascinated about this stuff and
when you guys move in let me know and
i'll come and cleanse and sage it and do
all that stuff for you guys
we were just saying that we wanted to do
that yeah i'll come and do it for you
guys because
i don't know my oldest places that's
amazing this past life
stuff really fascinates me i remember
you told sophia and i last time
that sophia in a past life was an old
man or just a man
an older man yes and that i was a young
girl
what does that mean for the for the
listeners that didn't hear the first one
remember what i told you about what
you're here for okay for the love and to
find to feel what it's like to have a
relationship have a family because you
didn't have that before
and then with her way of thinking being
being that man that male type of energy
coming back and having to get into her
femininity and the vulnerable side of
things
yeah i love that but that's why i'm
telling you guys that i don't feel like
this lifetime you guys are
neither one of you guys and i'm not just
saying this to be love and light that
you guys didn't come back to [ __ ] around
look at the look at the way the cards
were dealt for you in this lifetime
right that's true this is true
chris you have once again
literally the ending of this show i
don't
there's very few times where cece and i
are silent for longer than 10
seconds it's so hard to get us to shut
up yeah really
and you gotta be really speechless i
love you guys we love you
honestly it was like an instantaneous
connection and
we love you and we're always here for
you and we know that it's
the energy here is is so good and thank
you so
much and we will send you so many photos
of guys
yes please and also like i said don't
hesitate to reach out you guys are not
going to be bothering me you guys are
not going to be taking advantage of me
let me know when you want to come over
and do
the cleansing oh my gosh amazing okay
tell all of our listeners where they can
find
all of your stuff for okay first of all
you can find me uh booker reading at
chris medina dot guide
social media is at psychic chris m okay
perfect amazing and if you guys haven't
heard the first one with chris medina
please go back and listen to that
episode
that what watch that one before you
watch this one it'll make a lot of sense
definitely chris we love you thank you
again for coming thank you so much
thank you guys thank you guys for
listening to this week's episode
please check us out next week every
tuesday on unwax podcast instagram we're
on tick tock
you can check out our email which we
rarely open up so
check it out we love you guys see you
next week bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts spotify
follow your hosts at sophia stallone and
at sistine stallone
and be sure to follow the show at unwax
podcast we'll see you next week
[Music]